so Kosek X that's a reciprocal function
which one is it I'm sorry okay so even
if you don't know what Co say X looks
like it's not that hard to work out
because we know what sine looks like
okay so yes I mean this is I'll show you
my piece of paper in a second but I'll
go through the process doesn't then I'll
show you
sine X I'm going to put that in
different color so it looks something
like this okay
and I hate anything about it is that we
know that its range is minus 1 to 1
right so when you're taking the
reciprocal what's gonna happen what are
you gonna get things like wha 1 over 1
right whatever minus 1 is also minus 1
now what happens in between here since
I'm taking the reciprocal every time
sine X is 0
I hope you guys have a really good grab
I should put my own labels on all my
vertical asymptotes ransom is zero
that's fine and that's cheap I okay now
what does the rest of it look like how
about a few points on this it's kind of
like a parabola isn't it but it's not
because it has this these kinds of is
the kind of monotone okay Luxor and
upside down everything out okay that's
nice and okay
happy so yeah that's that is what I do
actually like this is so much so I I
just got my template out and I did my
sign X but I did a dotted said it's not
in the way of the actual graph cuz I
don't have a green pen so alright where
are we going soon now it starts to get
really funky really fast so this is the
kind of question I was talking about
before right where they're gonna ask you
to integrate something in the second
maybe that but you're not expected to
know what that is okay so that's why
they hold your hand through it sir
what's it six B beep okay I think they
say sure no I'm just trying to do it
from memory he said tell me if I get it
is that right okay now this is not that
hard this is just general right so walk
me through it let's see the left-hand
side now it's a log right it's a log so
general with a log function should be f
dash one F right - yeah and that's F in
there so what's f dash
okay chain rule or chain rule so there's
the inside of the inside
okay and tan just turns into SEC squared
no problems there's F - and then I'll
stick there from the world now I could
write as a fraction but because I'm
gonna get I know where I'm headed right
so I know this will just simplify out
nicely and are one of the void fractions
on fractions right so I'm gonna write
that here I know it doesn't make that
much of a difference but it was just be
a little neater okay ok SEC squared also
a reciprocal right so which one is it
so that twos down the bottom as well so
that's that term okay now this division
this is sign on cause so divisions turn
upside down so cause on a sign and you
can see what's happening right plus
cancels with this and I'm gonna have
double of half angle on the bottom yeah
okay so we need to be able to recognize
these kinds of things we're dealing with
trees pensions for a while okay so
that's just sine X okay now therefore
what am i us to do with this where did I
take it where's the other boundaries
okay so this is this is the classic
sound right so they've showed us this
weird derivative okay which we're going
to use in the next plot this is just so
let me get my downs and place again
that's just cursive right with respect
to X so they just trying to mess with
you okay just to put it light it in a
hot way right but I know what it's gonna
end up as I know what the primitive
function is because I just worked it out
so that's gonna be equal to you mean
these square brackets probably I
probably should approach to them what
else would it mean I'm all good okay so
now I can evaluate at my upper and lower
bounds right what am I gonna get okay so
10 of 10 all in PI over 3 times 16 is 4
3 right and then now even though what
you're gonna get will evaluate to 0
right you shouldn't skip it because it's
actually you're doing the evaluation at
the lower bound members so that's tanner
PI on 4 which is load 1 that's 0 and in
the same breath I'm gonna take that
index out the front because that's kind
of an easier way to write it
ok so in case you missed that that's
that's 3 the power of 1/2